-Today is Friday,
and that's usually when I catch
up on some personal stuff.
You know, I check my inbox,
I return some e-mails,
and of course,
I send out thank you notes.
And I was running
a bit behind today,
so I thought,
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd just like to write out
my weekly thank you notes
right now. Is that cool
with you guys?
Appreciate it.
James, can I get some thank you
note-writing music, please?
[ Solemn piano music plays ]
Concentrating.
[ Music stops ]
-He looks like he's suspicious.
-Shady.
-Worried about something.
-Yeah, he did something,
you know.
[ Music continues ]
Thank you, Joe Biden,
for releasing your tax returns,
although I'm not sure
you're actually allowed
to deduct malarkey.
[ Laughs ] What?
Tried to deduct malarkey, huh?
-And six pounds of it.
-Oh, wow.
♪♪
Thank you, Kim Jong-un,
banning mullets
and skinny jeans,
for letting the world know
that your biggest enemy
is apparently Billy Ray Cyrus
from 1992.
What's your problem?
Achy-breaky. [ Sniffs ]
Thank you,
getting handed your diploma,
for making me feel like
I'm participating
in a relay race
that took four years to finish.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Thank you,
graduation ceremonies,
for giving
students one final lesson --
how to dodge sharp pieces
of falling cardboard.
[ Imitates whooshing ]
[ Trills tongue ]
Hoo! Hoo! Psh!
They have any Avengers that
throw things like that?
-Don't they have, like,
that card guy, like, Gambit
or something like that?
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
-The gambler, he comes out
and he just takes the card
out of the deck of cards
and flips it at somebody?
That's it's pretty cool.
Does he trick first
and have them guess it?
-Maybe that's like --
-Your own murder weapon.
He's like, "Yeah but then --
but then Susie and Timmy,
they went to the store,
so then they got rid of it."
You know, they do
the whole story.
And they're like, "Well then,
well, where's Timmy?"
"This it?" And, you go,
"No, it's actually not."
He's like, "Well, I guess I
don't know how
to do magic, then."
"Wait a second.
Can you just check
your coat pocket for a second?"
It's Timmy!
And then you give it to him,
and he takes it and he goes,
[ Trilling tongue ]
Oooh!
-Is this your card?
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-You cut off my finger.
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Thank you, churros,
for being the only dessert
that looks like it was made
using a Play-Doh Fun Factory.
-That's not a churro.
♪♪
Thank you, Las Vegas
Hustler Club's
pop-up vaccine site
for not being the first pop-up
that's happened at a strip club.
-Oh, hey!
[ Rim shot ]
Uh-oh!
Oy!
Polling station?
-No.
[ Laughs ] Johnson &...Johnson.
-[ Laughs ] Hey!
-Three -- three Johnsons.
-[ Blowing ] Get ready for it.
You can do it,
you can do it.
You got them ready?
-Do I got what ready?
-Is that your card?
That wasn't my card.
[ Groans ]
[ Rim shot ]
-That's right. This was.
-[ Shouting ] You're right.
It was the Seven of Spades.
[ Groaning ]
Wait, this card is a Joker.
So, yes, it was my card.
I'm dying now.
I'm about to lose my life.
Let me --
-Hey, hey.
-I know --
-[ Groans, trills tongue ]
This is a card for 20% off
at Bed Bath & Beyond.
Ah! I think I'm beyond that!
-[ Laughs ] Here you go, then.
-[ Shouting ] Oh, my gosh.
This is a Diner's Club card
for 60s free --
-Let's just call it
a misunderstanding.
I'll see you next week, OK?
-OK, alright.
[ Imitates popping ] Oh.
-Here we go.
♪♪
Thank you, cabinet full of
old spices.
It's nice to know
I can freshen up any meal
with some garlic powder
from 2006.
C'mon, it still works.
Just bang it on the counter.
-It's solid now.
-Exactly.
You scrape it off, like...
[ imitates scraping ]
-You just get a grater.
-Yeah.
-Makes it better,
because it's "grater."
-A little cheesy...
-Nice.
-...But still sharp.
-Ah!
That was a "gouda" joke.
[ Rim shot ]
-Yeah, I guess we're
"fonduing" it.
[ Rim shot ]
♪♪
Thank you, crayons,
for starting out pristine
and ending up like
a post-battle scene
from "Game of Thrones".
There you have it.
Those are our thank you notes.